مؤتمر الامن بميونخ في عام الحرب وقبل
اسبوع من الذكرى الاولى للصراع المسلح
الذي غير اوروبا والعالم بتدعيته السابقه
واللاحقه جدول اعمال مختلف وحضور ايضا
مختلف في غياب الضيف المعتاد وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
الوفد الامريكي المشارك هذه السنه لافته
جدا من حيث العدد وثقل وكثره الملفات
المطروحه حاليا
افتتحت اعمال المؤتمر بكلمه عن بعد للراس
الاوكراني فلودي قال فيها ما سمع من قبل
وكرر منشدته للتعجيل بجهود دعم الغرب
لبلاده
نحتاج الى السرعه سرعه في ابرام اتفاقاتنا
سرعه في الامدادات لتعزيز معركتنا سرعه في
القرارات للحد من القدره الروسيه لا بديل
عن انتصار اوكرانيا لا بديل عن اوكرانيا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي
حذر الحضور من ان بلاده لن تكون المحطه
الاخيره للرئيس بوتين الانشغال الكبير
للاوروبيين بحرب اوكرانيا لا يقلل بل على
العكس يرفع درجه حراره النقاشات المتعلقه
بمستقبل القاره وامنها اكثر من اي وقت مضى
من بينها الى اي مدى ينبغي ان تعزز اوروبا
قدراتها العسكريه والى اي حد يمكنها
الاعتماد على الولايات المتحده في امنها
وكم ينبغي ان تنفق الحكومات على الدفاع
كلام المستشار الالماني
يصب في هذا الاتجاه شدد على ضروره بناء
القدرات الدفاعيه لاوروبا والنيتو وايضا
على الحذر من الانزلاق في الصراع الدائر
اقول للرئيس الروسي ليس اسلحتنا ما سيطيل
امد الحرب وانما متى ما فهم بوتين استحاله
تحقيق اهدافه فان نهايه الحرب ستكون اسرع
سنعمل على تحقيق التوازن بين د عم
اوكرانيا عسكريا وعدم اندلاع حرب بين
النيتو وروسيا
حرمته
روسيا مستفزه من انخراط الولايات المتحده
في الحرب لم يعد هناك شك صرحت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه وهي تصف تصريحات المستشاره
الامريكيه للشؤون السياسيه بالعبثيه
يمكننا الاستنتاج من جديد انخراط الولايات
المتحده في الصراع في اوكرانيا فهي تسلم
كم من كبيرا من السلاح والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وتشارك في التخطيط المباشر
للعمليات القتاليه
تقريبا بعد عام من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
لافقا لنهايه القتال ولا فرصه للانخراط في
مسار تفوضي قد يحدد جدولا زمنيا لتضع
الحرب اوزارها اخيرا كل الدعم الغربي غير
المسبوق لدوله واحده في مواجهه روسيا
والعقوبات الاقصى في التاريخ ضد موسكو لم
تغير الكثير في مشهد حرب مستمره ضحاياها
المباشرون وغير المباشرين كثر وبتداعيات
لحدود لها ثلاثه ايام هي مده مؤتمر ميونخ
للمفارقه انعقد العمل ماضي قبل ايام قليله
من حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا اما هذا العام
فالسياق صراع قلب الحسابات وبدل الاولويات
وغير تحالفات العالم المعلنه منها
والمستتره